thank you for coming I am Carrie Robin
the programming coordinator for st.
Louis County Library and I'm very
pleased to present tonight's program
with acclaim sports historian Lee
Montville I'd like to thank our
presenting sponsor Maryville University
and our bookseller Barnes & Noble the
team from the Chesterfield Barnes &
Noble has the books for sale in the back
of the room please do consider buying
the book tonight purchasing the book
helps support this author series and
help us bring more great authors to st.
Louis Lee will sign copies at this table
after the talk we just line you up by
row and get it going very efficiently so
tonight's event is presented by the buzz
Westfall favorite author series this
program was started in 2004 and presents
authors of politics history and sports
you can visit the program for a list of
the businesses and organizations that
sponsor the Westfall series our next
Westfall event will be next month know
next Tuesday May 23rd we're gonna host
our first fiction writer in the Westfall
series when Jeff Shara will be here he
is a writer who writes sort of military
histories it's all history based but
they're sort of novelizations with
historical events in this book is called
the frozen hours and is about the Korean
War but on to tonight's program Lee
Montville is a former columnist at the
Boston Globe and a former senior writer
for Sports Illustrated
he's written New York Times bestselling
biographies of such iconic and
fascinating sports figures as Babe Ruth
Ted Williams Evel Knievel and Dale
Earnhardt tonight he will share his new
biography of one of the most celebrated
and controversial athletes of the 20th
century
Muhammad Ali which is very appropriately
titled sting like a beam Montville
narrows his focus to a somewhat
overlooked period of Ali's life his
circle as a conscientious Draft objector
during the tumultuous Vietnam era and
the subsequent legal battle that took
him all the way to the Supreme Court
masterfully researched and told with
great suspense sting like a bee is an
inspiring account of
highs and lows of an exceptional
individual and never fails to capture
the charisma and complexity of Muhammad
Ali please help me welcome Lee Montel
[Applause]
thank you for that nice introduction
it's nice to be in st. Louis I
celebrated from Nautica discount outlet
and the last time I bought a new pair of
pants to come to one of these I gave the
whole talk and I walked out and I saw
again along the side of the pants
it was a long plastic thing that said 32
by 30 32 by 30 33 30 and so I was very
careful in taking the pants and
straightening things out Muhammad Ali
that this should be like the greatest
book talk ever the greatest book talk of
all time because we're talking about
Muhammad Ali you say there's a million
books on Muhammad Ali out there and why
should there be another book and that's
a very good question why is this guy
writing this book but the last book I
wrote was about Evel Knievel and I
finished that and we were talking what I
should do next with my publisher and I
think most writers want to do sort of an
obscure story that nobody knows sort of
the Seabiscuit kind of thing where
America all of a sudden discovers this
great story and and falls in love with
it and so I I proposed doing a book
about a guy named will McDonough who was
a writer at the Boston Globe when I was
there heard he had some mob connections
and things like that and told great
stories and he was probably the most
charismatic guy I knew and my editor
said well could you write out about a 25
page proposal on this and I did I wrote
out the 25 page proposal and he turned
it down in about five seconds and he
said
you need to write about some iconic
athlete so I run a list of iconic
athletes you know and I wrote I don't
know Johnny Unitas Bill Russell you know
Walter Payton and they all seem to have
been done they were all there were all
books on those guys and then I put down
Muhammad Ali and I said that's the most
iconic guy of all I mean he's the most
iconic athlete that's ever been in the
United States been in the world and I
said maybe there's something in there
and that the time period I came up with
on the the last big book on Muhammad Ali
was was written by the the editor of The
New Yorker David Remnick and it was
written in 1997 and it covered the time
in Ali's life from when he was born in
Louisville till he won the World title
and fought Sonny Liston and Menendez
that that went from there and when he
had the trouble would be with the draft
board and the United States government
and and kind of go with that and and I
said that to my editor and and I gave
him that the proposed title you know
Muhammad Ali versus the United States of
America and he said could you write me
two paragraphs on that and so I wrote
the two paragraphs and the next day
called up and said we got a deal we're
gonna do this so that's all I'm doing it
and and I found as I got into it there
are a couple of great reasons to be
doing it I'm eighteen months younger
than Muhammad Ali was and so I was going
through the same stuff with the draft
and the Vietnam War and the six days and
I got married around the same time as
him and his draft problems came up
around the time my draft problems came
up and so that that that I really hooked
in on that that the Vietnam War kind of
changed a lot of lives just about
everybody I'd say my age kind of was
affected somehow
I mean I knew guys that got married to
stay out of the draft I knew guys who
started careers in education when they
had no reason to be an education and
they've been in education all their
lives because of the draft because you
get a deferment I myself I would have
gone I graduated from the University of
Connecticut I would I would have gone to
Paris or somewhere like that and kind of
bummed around for a while but you really
couldn't do that so I went to 15
different National Guard outfits and you
know said gee I'd love to go there and I
found some outfit that actually needed
somebody and and I wound up and free in
Fort Jackson and the first time I flew
on an airplane it was from Fort Jackson
to st. Louis to go to Fort Leonard Wood
and we actually hitchhiked once to st.
Louis from from Fort Leonard Wood we
stayed in some kids room at Washington
University and then we went to hitchhike
back and we got stranded in Rolla
Missouri we we stood by the exit there
for six hours waiting for somebody to
pick us up and finally a guy came he had
a truck that only had that third gear
was stripped and he he kind of chugged
over and he picked us up and he took us
home I promise to God that I would I had
from that moment on that I would always
pick up every hitchhiker that I saw but
I I kind of broke that promise section
and I'm sorry God so the draft affected
everyone in Muhammad Ali when he first
the first thing that happened with
Muhammad Ali was in 1964 writer when we
when he was fighting Sonny Liston he was
called up to go for his draft physical
and at the age of 18 and he went for the
physical and the mental test and he
flunked the mental test he he really
couldn't read very well and and couldn't
write very well and and math was was
probably he was dyslexic I think and so
he flunked the the mental test and then
he flunked it again
and he had a score
of like 16 on the test and and that that
was underneath the barrier plus then he
got married so he was out in two
different things he was four off and he
was married well then he he fought sunny
less than a second time and he got
divorced they had during the Nation of
Islam and he got divorced because his
wife wouldn't conform to the Nation of
Islam
she wouldn't dress like that and
wouldn't follow the religion and so he
now is eligible that way and Vietnam was
just chewing up people and so they they
drop they dropped the test and so now
his 16 passed the test
instead of flunked the test and he was
called in to be in the service and he
was called in to he was changed to 1a
and that happened that happened in 1966
and I'll kind of read you what he said
when that happened he said you can edit
out this part where he looks for the
looks for the thing in the book when he
when he when he was reclassified 1a and
the reporters all stood around outside
outside he had gone into training to
fight he was gonna fight Ernie Terrell
in Chicago and he was in Miami Beach
when he found out and he came out in
front of this house where he was living
and reporters put put on the cameras and
stuff and he said he said this he said I
can't understand how they can do this to
me why be anxious to take me a man who
pays the salary of at least two hundred
thousand men a year two hundred thousand
men you hear I can't understand out of
all the baseball players all the
football players all the basketball
players why seek out me who's the
world's only heavyweight champion why
are they so anxious to pay me $80 a
month me who in two fights for six who
in two fights pays for six
new jet planes I'm fighting for the
government every day I'm laying my life
on the line for the government every day
9 out of 10 soldiers wouldn't what not
want to be in my place in the ring it's
too dangerous for two years the army
told everybody I was a nut and I was
ashamed and now they decide I'm a wise
man they embarrassed my parents
everybody was asking them questions
asking me asking them if I was a nut
even my ex-wife was ashamed you had
bothered me a bit
now without ever testing to testing me
to see if I'm wiser or worser than
before they decide I can go in the army
so he said all that stuff and more and
the next day he gave that the quote that
became famous or infamous around the
country was I I don't have any quarrel
with those Vietcong and that kind of
seemed to be at the time you know when
the war was was just kind of picking up
and it almost seemed seditious you know
that that he was he was like aligned
himself with the enemy and his his
popularity kind of just went down in a
minute and the fight with Ernie Terrell
was cancelled in Chicago and and a whole
bunch of stuff he he took a big public
relations hit and the reason he objected
to the war was because he was a member
of the Nation of Islam it that was his
total reason he was a true believer in
in the Nation of Islam and the Nation of
Islam was sort of an offshoot of Islam
with with a different a different kind
of theology on the side of of the white
devils and and oppressing the the black
man and and in just a different theology
and the idea was why should a black man
fight in the white man's war the
Honorable Elijah Muhammad who was the
head of the Nation of Islam he had
served four years in jail during World
War two and a bunch of members of the
religion at
serve time in jail for not going to
Korea and Muhammad Ali was was in that
line and in his religious thinking and
so he applied for conscientious objector
status which which entailed a bunch of
things he he had a lawyer named Edward
Jacko who had been a big lawyer from
Malcolm X in the Nation of Islam up in
Harlem he was called Jaco the Giant
Killer because he had beaten the
government on a bunch of things and they
filed a thing for conscientious objector
and as part of that he had to go see a
special judge that they brought in a
retired judge this is part of that the
apparatus for applying is a
consciousness and just objector they
brought in a retired judge to talk to
decide whether or not he should be a
conscientious objector and this was
Ali's one time that he could really
state his case and the guy here was 65
years old
his name was Lawrence Grauman and he was
in Louisville Kentucky and he wasn't
known as a big civil rights guy at all
you know he was kind of a country club
guy in Louisville and you wouldn't think
he would alley would have much of a
chance and he had a new lawyer now a guy
named Hayden Covington who had been a
defender of the Jehovah's Witnesses for
a long time and Hayden Covington had
been the most successful lawyer ever to
appeal cases to the US Supreme Court he
had gotten a lot of Jehovah's Witnesses
out of serving in the army and there'd
been a lot of cases about your host
witnesses refusing to to say the Pledge
of Allegiance and stand and salute the
flag and things like that so they they
went they went before this judge Grauman
Ally stated his case the FBI presented a
file and judge Grauman went off to
decide on this and after about three
weeks
judge Grauman decided that Ali should be
a conscientious objector and he filed
his thing with the Justice Department
and it was a non-binding decision and
the Justice Department said well that's
very nice which what judge Grauman said
but we think you draft board 47 really
should consider Muhammad Ali 1a and he
should be drafted so the Justice
Department overrode what he said what
judge Grauman said in a way we went for
this whole thing were eventually Ali was
called for induction into the army and
in Houston and who refused to step
forward and that caused him to every
every state that is starting to starting
with the New York Athletic Commission
every state kind of rescinded his
heavyweight championship and and took it
away and did the Justice Department had
his passport suspended so he couldn't go
anywhere else in the world to fight so
he was out of a job and a three and a
half year period started then he got
married again to a 17 year old girl
Belinda Boyd who was a member of the
Nation of Islam had kind of had had
grown up in the Nation of Islam school
and her parents are friends with the
Honorable Elijah Muhammad and she
probably knew more about the religion
than anybody and the two of them kind of
went off to figure out life and he was
making no money he had spent all this
money and he wound up doing these
college college campus things where he
went around to colleges and presented
his case to the college kids and m'as
n't he wasn't part of the draft board
apparatus II into the great protests of
going against the draft he was
protesting mostly for himself he wasn't
with the kids that were burning their
draft cards he wasn't with the the
beragon brothers and the peer and the
priests who were going in and
pouran cows blood on the draft records
and all of that stuff he was off kind of
protesting on his on his own on his own
route and he wasn't a civil rights guy
either he was the the Nation of Islam
belief belief was separation not
integration and he once said if he if he
voted if he could vote he would have
voted for George Wallace that he wanted
a segregated Society where were the
black men would have they they give him
a state or something or a couple states
and and it would be almost a separate
country and so he he and in fact you
know he would he would call the people
that were marching under under the
Reverend Martin Luther King he would say
what are you doing this isn't this isn't
a thing you should be doing there if
people don't want you you shouldn't be
trying to force yourself upon them he
said we should go off in a different
direction so he he he had a very
different viewpoint than then then he
had later in life I think and he was
very controversial and the funny thing
happened as he was doing all these
college dates and in a couple years went
by 1968 came along where everything went
crazy that was maybe the craziest year
going when Martin Luther King was
assassinated Robert Kennedy was
assassinated there was that convention
with with with Mayor Daley in Chicago
there were riots in 110 cities in
America just a whole bunch of stuff I
mean a guy tried to assassinate Andy
Warhol stuff was just going on
everywhere and Muhammad Ali just didn't
seem that controversial anymore and as
the war had had ground along more and
more kids had convinced their parents
that maybe this wasn't the greatest war
in the world for them to be involved in
and had had kind of rebelled against the
thing and slowly but surely the National
perception of Muhammad Ali had become
much different and when he finally got
to the end of 68 and 69 it there's a
great thing he was on he was on firing
line with William F Buckley I don't know
if anybody remembers that show you know
William F Buckley was the area did
erudite guy with the big words and the
whole thing and he was arguing with
Muhammad Ali Muhammad Ali was very good
against him I mean he he'd gone off and
and perfected his rap you know and and
in all these college things and arguing
with college kids and and he was very
good in that show and different things
along those lines came he showed up I'm
more and more on Johnny Carson and Merv
Griffin and the Mike Douglas show and
and he became more mainstream he
appeared to play on Broadway and slowly
but surely the idea came maybe he should
be back fighting and a guy in New York a
young civil rights lawyer
they Mike Michael Meltzer he had kind of
filed a whole thing in New York to get
his license back because he said Ali was
really you know he really hadn't been
convicted of anything he was still in
the appeals process how could he lose
his job for something that he hadn't can
be been convicted for that wasn't an
American kind of thing and so that had
gone on and another guy had tried to to
get him a license in Atlanta Georgia
where in Georgia wasn't the state boxing
commission that that licensed fights it
was the city boxing commission so under
the nose of lester maddox they're
probably the most segregationist
governor in america they they they push
through the thing in Atlanta and he
assigned to fight Jerry quarry as his
comeback fight and he he fought Jerry
quarry in 1970 and then New York thing
had opened up and he fought he fought
Oscar
beat Jerry quarry in three rounds cut
him up pretty bad and they stopped the
fight and then he fought Oscar Bonavena
in Madison Square Garden and that that
fight went the distance twelve rounds
and he won the decision and then he was
signed to fight Joe Frazier the fight
that had been building and building and
building Frazier had become the champion
in absentia and Ali can consider himself
to be the people's champion and it got
built up and it was probably the biggest
sports event in the in 20th century
America you know it was just huge each
fighter got five million dollars which
was an unbelievable amount of money at
that time and Jack Kent Cooke
who was the owner of the Washington
Redskins and whatever he was the one
that put up the ten million dollars and
they fought and an ally for some reason
this fight of his life this comeback
fight of his his his of his life really
didn't didn't train that hard for it he
wound up spending most of his training
time talking to reporters and hanging
around and and doing stuff in the
meantime Frazier was grinding away and
grinding away and grinding away and
Ali's wife told him she said you're
gonna lose to this guy I don't even want
to sit I don't want to even want to sit
in the good seats I'm gonna sit way in
the bad seats because you know and sure
enough Frazier just ground away and
ground away and in the 14th round
knocked a lead down and in Frazier won
the fight he wanted when a decision and
about two months later the case finally
came before the Supreme Court it it had
gone to the Supreme Court once and the
Supreme Court had refused to rule on it
which would which would have sent Ali to
jail but a second thing came up about
about wiretapping and the FBI had
wiretapped some of the constant
conversations
Nellie just five of them without his
knowledge and so that brought him back
for another chance to go through the
courts and and go to the Supreme Court
and it reached the Supreme Court and the
Supreme Court decided Judge Thurgood
Marshall recused himself because he had
been part of the Justice Department
prosecuting Ally way back when all this
started before he became a Supreme Court
justice so it was eight eight judges
were voting and the vote was five to
three that Ali was convicted and and he
was going to go away he was going to go
away for five years after the Joe
Frazier fight and then Judge John Harlan
was given the the job of writing up this
majority opinion that Muhammad Ali was
going to go away and he of course the
scientist his his his like his interns
is his law clerks to to write the
opinion and the law clerks really were
again that they were part of the young
people who would you know changed the
mind about Muhammad Ali and they figured
out a way to convince John Harlan that
that Muhammad Ali really should have got
a deferment you know as a conscientious
objector way back there in the beginning
when the Justice Department had had
turned over what Lawrence Graham and the
judge the judge had had ruled so John
Harlan to his credit kind of believed
the clerks and he went back to the
Supreme Court and he said I changed my
vote so now it's four to four and and
it's a tie and Muhammad Ali still would
go to jail with a tie but one of the
other justices part of Stuart said what
kind of decision is that people in
America will look at this famous guy
this famous case and say oh my god the
court can't make up his mind and he
still has to go to jail so they said
about kind of looking for a way to get
him out of the to change the vote and
and to get him off the hook and they
found some wording in the Justice
Department's decision
on Lawrence Grauman's thing that the
kind of seemed contradictory so they all
voted eight to nothing and le was off
the hook and he was off into the world
and that's the whole time period that's
covered in the book it kind of ends
right there and as we know there there
was a whole bunch of his life that was
lived afterwards I had had problems
figuring out what the introduction was
to this book I was doing it for a couple
years and I tried out a few
introductions and I couldn't do it and
then Ali died and and there was such an
outpouring of emotion it was like like
Gandhi had died her mother Teresa had
died and and you know the funeral was
shown live on television and and you
know Billy Crystal and all these people
were talking and and and it was oh it
was all great stuff but it it kind of
you didn't see where the edge was what
was going on at the time what where the
friction was what was what was happening
and I said well that's what my book is
showing what the edge was and what the
friction was Ali at the end of his
career you know he became sick and and
in it he just for the last half of his
life was more of an inspirational figure
than anything and he he did some
wonderful stuff and I think a lot of
qualities were assigned to him that he
that he had in the second half of his
life that maybe he didn't have in the
first half when he was a much more
controversial guy and he's a fascinating
guy and I think they'll forever be the
most interesting athlete an iconic guy
that we've ever seen anybody want ask
some questions but
for the questions yep evel knievel or
anybody else that works about how are
the funds provided for his defense
all the years it was not boxing and just
lecturing well yeah that's a good
question
the Jehovah's Witness the Jehovah's
Witness lawyer Hayden Covington he quit
because they were stephane him for the
money
and that's why he wound up doing it and
a civil rights attorney from Atlanta
named Charles Morgan who had been he'd
been involved in a whole bunch of civil
rights things there since the the
Birmingham March and the bombing of the
church and and Birmingham he became
involved and then at the end the Legal
Defense Fund with which which helped in
civil rights cases kind of did it pro
bono and in Charles but Morgan did it
pro bono and and the guy the the guy who
did the work in the New york-new to get
his license back in New York he did that
pro bono he was a Legal Defense Fund guy
- can you address the rumors that have
persisted about a lead not stepping
forward to be sworn in because he feared
for his life under the threat of perhaps
being killed by members of the Nation of
Islam if he went and was drafted there
was there's one thing in a book about
Sugar Ray Robinson Sugar Ray Robinson
talked about a league coming to see him
on at the Lowe's Midtown Motor Inn well
the night before he was going to fight
Zora Folley in saying that he was
terrified and everything but but he
truly I don't I don't buy it I I think
he truly believed in the Nation of Islam
and was very strong in the Nation of
Islam and you know for sure there were
some tough guys in the Nation of Islam I
mean they they didn't kill Malcolm I
count Mack Malcolm
and and and they they did some things to
Kareem abdul-jabbar also but I I think
he was just a true believer I really do
he you know he he went to when he when
he got the Olympic gold medal he he was
backed by by this group in Louisville of
eleven white businessmen and they hired
Angelo Dundee to be his trainer and they
sent him down to Miami Florida and it
was all good Angelo was a great trainer
but Angelo went home it that you know
not at five o'clock every night and here
was this 18 year old kid down there
trying to figure out and make
connections in life and meet people and
do things and and that's when when he
fell and throbbed with the Nation of
Islam and it became it really became his
life you know you exude so I I don't
think he was afraid you never talked to
him
never well I I covered his last but I
covered five fights of his but they were
after this time period but but no for
the book now he was kind of out of it
and so talk about the the direct
research and who'd I mean you had a lot
of newspaper accounts and things but
what about direct interviews and things
you talked a lot with his wife at the
time Linda Boyd her name now is kalila
Camacho Ali and she she had a good point
she said that Ali always the narrative
Ali controlled the narrative to his life
better than anybody control the
narrative because people would just
listen to Ali and he would give him so
many great quotes they never go talk to
anybody and they never hear anything
else run to anybody else and she was
very interested in she was kind of tough
on him because because their life ended
badly with his womanizing and
I mean that there's a famous scene where
where the Thrilla in Manilla she was
home with the kids in Chicago and he was
with Veronica Porsche who was his
girlfriend and they went to see Imelda
Marcos or Ferdinand Marcos and he said
your wife is just a beautiful woman and
Ali said thank you very much and Belinda
Saudis in Chicago and she went right to
the airport and got on a plane and flew
right to Manila and came to the hotel
room and raised raised a huge ruckus and
then turned around and came and got back
on the same plane that she had flown
they were refueling the plane and she
came back to the Chicago and and that
was kind of the end of there at the end
of their marriage so she had interesting
things to say other questions
oh my god sure
know that that said that that the Nation
of Islam once the Honorable Elijah
Muhammad passed away his son his son
changed the Nation of Islam over to like
a Sunni Muslim kind of parted part of
Islam and and Ali went with that and the
Reverend Lewis Fowler can about three or
four years later reinstituted the Nation
of Islam and when he broke with Elijah
Muhammad's son so now he became just a
for lack of better words a normal Muslim
for the rest of his life which was which
is what happened with with Malcolm
access or Malcolm X got in trouble with
the Nation of Islam because he had
become a regular Muslim and not a member
of the Nation of Islam yes sir
powerful self always there when they
yeah I think they were friends but I
think it was a business relationship to
you know I mean I think I think they
both got a lot out of it from from each
of their perspectives you know Howard
Howard afforded him a stage to work on
and he afforded Howard a stage to work
on I think they were friendly but I I
don't think they they went out to dinner
a lot you know he le was walking out was
walking out of one of his court dates
with one of his lawyers and we said - he
said - a rapport and he said I don't
have any white friends and reporter said
well right hearing your lawyers a white
man is he your friend he said he's my
lawyer he's not my friend you know so I
think that yeah they were friendly but I
you know I they didn't they didn't go
over to each other's house all the time
yes sir I was just students for a sure
was that legitimate you never knew with
him you know early on early on when he
came back when he came back from the
Olympics he thought he you know the
streets were gonna be paved with gold
and he would he would just just start to
fight and to be sellouts and people
would go crazy but it you know he had to
fight a whole bunch of people and that
most sports fans didn't know about to
kind of build up a record and he wasn't
getting crowds at all and what he did he
he met gorgeous George who was the
wrestler and gorgeous George his whole
thing was aren't I pretty aren't I good
and he had blond peroxide hair he threw
out bobby pins and he had he had a
ballet they would spray perfume on him
and things like that and gorgeous George
would just pack these arenas and people
would go crazy and Allie looked at it
and he said well that's how you do it
you know if you're a villain you get
people to come out and that's he he kind
of added that to his act and that that
was what he did was Sonny Liston and and
you know the bear I'm gonna beat the
bear and you know and he just he made
himself into a villain but which was all
well and good but then when the draft
thing came up he became the villain plus
you know because he he had said these
these things that the most of America
didn't didn't like at the time you know
and you know you wonder if Ally were
around today in his in his prime what
would it be like you know and I say if
if you look at Cole and Kaepernick you
know and you say people had a lot of
problems with Colin Kaepernick they
would have had ten times the problems
with Muhammad Ali you know Colin
Kaepernick wasn't doing anything he just
wouldn't stand for the national anthem
you know he was just protested and so he
would have he would be a very
controversial guy today and in the
situation yes sir
research discounts he ever reimbursed
financially for for his loss of
employment during that time after his
case was ruled upon favorably and then
to partment and was there any other
precedent set with this for any other
conscious of conscientious objector
cases that followed or maybe his case
set a precedent for the answers are no
and no the the first know is in a way
though he was reimbursed in that
everything was so big when he came back
you know if if he hadn't gone away for
the three years would he and Frasier
have gotten five million dollars of
peace to fight each other you know at
that that's what made that whole thing
him him coming from the desert you know
and Frasier being here and just
colliding you know I remember watching
that fight I went I had and live in
Boston and I went to this that there was
a nightclub Caesars Monticello
Framingham Massachusetts and the whole
place I took my wife and she was young
and we were there it was nine million
guys and they were all half drunk and
the whole place went crazy and Tiny Tim
had walked in everybody Tiny Tim Tiny
Tim and it was just a crazy time that
was it
that was a you know Frank Sinatra took
pictures for Life magazine you know
stuff that oh oh and there were no there
were no precedents you know if if
Muhammad Ali was just another guy it he
kind of got celebrity justice in the
first part you know singled out because
because he was because because the
things he had said and so he was kind of
singled out and classified 1a and
eligible for the draft but at the end he
got saved with celebrity justice because
you know his reputation was such so but
it's it's an odd thing the the way it
all went and if he had been another guy
he would have been you know either in
the service or in Levin
I think you know he he had legal he had
lawyers to back him up any more
questions
right just come over with the microphone
so that I remember his his later years
and how weak he looked from my guests
Parkinson's disease did he ever talk
about that and whether how boxing had
affected the rest of his life well I
mean you know I it's an easy it's an
easy pop medicine kind of thing to say
that boxing is what happened you know I
mean the rope-a-dope and all that way
where he was just letting people pound
on him and the cumulative effects of all
the things I you know that at the moment
where he lit the torch in 1996 in
Atlanta was a huge huge iconic moment
you know Janet Evans gives them the the
torch and he's you know and and I think
America watched it with a whole with a
whole bunch of different emotions going
on you know and part of it I think his
guilt you know that you got so much
enjoyment from this guy and he was so
interesting with all the way he talked
and the way he acted in the thoughts he
he made you think and and you kind of
you kind of led him to this in a way
because he you cheered him on as a boxer
and stuff so I think there was some
guilt and there and and and some
definite devotion you know he he
certainly he certainly what while he
wasn't part of the anti-war movement per
se and he wasn't part of the civil
rights movement per se he certainly got
a lot of people talking about that stuff
and people people kind of used him as a
model to defer for act for action you
know to just stand up to the government
to to kind of go for your rights a you
know in the end that's that that's what
his image was
in your research did you ever come
across anything on Joe Frazier being in
a service or having served in the
service no Joe Frazier Joe Frazier had a
lot of kids real early you know and and
that kind of kept him out
but but he always he was always very
patriotic you know like like five or six
days after after the the fight in 1971
where he beat Ali the one time he was in
the White House with Nixon next and and
Ellie said that Alec before the fight
Ali said that he said Joe Frazier will
be to be there with Nixon he said Nixon
will have anything to do with me but
that was part of Ali's rap about the
whole thing I was at the airport here
silver years many years ago yeah
flight from Atlanta came in and guess
who came off the plane and we locked
eyes just very briefly and without even
thinking about it my hand went out to
him and he put his hand out to me we
shook hands I I just met the most famous
guy out probably over me he was very
friendly he wasn't put off ashore
anything like that it was we had a great
curiosity about people I think you know
and I think that that overrode a whole
lot of stuff you know he was very
pleasant very glib my my big memory of
the first fight I covered it covered him
was in when it when he fought Chuck
Wepner there's a movie just came out
about Chuck Wepner and I was young and I
went and it was at Richfield Ohio right
outside Cleveland it was 45 minutes from
Cleveland so I rented a car I was there
for the Boston Globe and I rent in a car
and so I drove out to the way in the day
before the fight and I didn't know that
the media mostly got on a bus and went
out and then they got taken back on a
bus so I drove out in the car and after
the way it everybody got on the bus but
I was still there and I said well maybe
she'd go to Muhammad Ali's dressing room
and check it out maybe I could get
something different and so I went and I
I went in and there was no security
nothing and I went went in and there may
be I don't know seven or eight people in
there and he was stretched out on a
rubbing table and his his back was kind
of up against the wall and Billy
Eckstine the singer that old black magic
James Brown the singer Papa got a brand
new bag he was there and Redd Foxx was
there and Redd Foxx was telling dirty
jokes and Redd Foxx is from st. Louis I
guess and red fog he was telling that
the best dirty jokes I've ever heard in
my life and he would tell and
everybody's sides were just splitting
you know and tears were in their eyes
and and we'd all be kind of in Le would
say tell another one and red flash said
tell another one it was even more dirty
and even better than the last one and
and it was like a moment you know I just
in that moment I kept saying I wish they
could this could go on forever you know
maybe James Brown will start singing
maybe somebody else come in and the
whole thing but I I kind of I kind of
peeled out and there you know I was just
a little Howdy Doody guy standing there
and and I kind of peeled out chuck
wepner's dressing room and Chuck and his
wife were there and they were all by
themselves and and we talked and it was
nice and that there's a famous the
famous quote from Chuck Wepner before
the fighting he bought us he brought his
wife a flimsy negligee and he said I
want you to wear this tonight when you
go to bed with the heavyweight champion
of the world see he goes and he fights
and he he puts up a credible thing they
base rocky and chuck wepner's fight
against Muhammad Ali but he gets caught
up and he goes to the hospital and
stitched up and it's 3:30 4:00 o'clock
and the more and he gets back and his
wife is sitting there and she's got the
negligee on and she says well is he
coming down here
I was interested in your comments
paraphrase it Ali was the most iconic
athlete to guess US history I think you
said and you've written about Ruth and
Ted Williams and a number of others so
quickly who who else do you list is
iconic and is are there any quick
answers response why alleys number one
and then aside of that
what what were your impressions and did
you respect evil okay one thing le was
le was global I mean that that's the
difference you know Babe Ruth was a semi
global but but le was global you know
and and everybody knew him he was
probably one of the I don't know for
most known people in the world when he
was going on right up there with
presidents and so he was the biggest
iconic I I don't know I mean we all know
all those people you know the the famous
athletes you know I suppose the iconic
is touched to your age to you know it
you know if you say Johnny Unitas maybe
that says you're a certain age or if you
say you know Walter Payton or Jim Brown
or you know but I mean all those people
are iconic in their own respects and
Evel Knievel no Evel Knievel was a bad
guy he you know there's a lot of talk
about narcissism today he he he was a
narcissistic guy with big hair so I
don't know you know how you want to
relate that to our present situation
you might take one or two more yeah
anybody else I was just curious to know
if Laila Ali is the daughter of Belinda
Boyd or someone else no Layla was Layla
was later Layla was later after after
after he was the Veronica Porsche and he
he had some children to that there
weren't with any of his wives he he he
did a lot it lot to propagate the future
of America hey is there one more
question or should we sign some books
okay well thank you so much okay again
the book is for sale in the back of the
room from Barnes & Noble and Lee will be
right here at this table and we'll get
you guys some books